There's a phrase associated with
NASA: failure is not an option.
But there's another
one in innovation
that is fail fast and fail often.
It's a world of both.
Iris is the first American
robot on the moon.
It is the first university-built.
It is the first student-led.
The first for proving
the capability of small rovers.
This is like teaching
a baby to walk.
And before it gets to that million
critical steps on another planet,
there'll be tens of
millions here on earth.
My name is Red Whittaker.
I'm a professor of robotics.
This is my 50th year
at Carnegie Mellon.
I created the Iris idea.
And from that produced
the very first course
that engaged and
enrolled students
and fostered it to and through
where we are right now.
Copy that.
Looks like we're taking the rough
average of our estimates.
I'd say, still recommend
backward 15.
Right.
Requesting permission to move
backwards 15 centimeters
at five centimeters per second.
Iris is a shoebox on wheels.
It is going to the moon to
prove that small is capable.
Iris is two kilograms, has very
bottlecap-wheel design
made out of carbon fiber.
Very, very small compared
to typical SUV-sized rovers.
The technology that has built
Iris over the years has really
stemmed from various projects
that date back to the ‘80s,
when Red really became
interested in space robotics
and lunar robotics.
I formulated this notion
of developing thinking
machines that work in the
world and worlds beyond.
Never changed one word of it
and never ran out of
anything great to do.
The one that's left
on the checklist is
robots to worlds beyond.
It takes a few wealthy individuals
who are willing to invest
their own time and money
and who are excited about space
to start this social movement.
It's generating the imagination.
It's really bringing the
excitement back into space.
It's opening doors
and opportunities
that really weren't here before.
One of the biggest things
about this project is that it's
not a government entity.
Because it's a student project,
reaching out to the community
is such a huge part
of this venture.
And so having the students
do a crowdfunding campaign,
learning how that process works,
it's something that is
a really unique opportunity
to bring everybody in and show
that anybody can
make it to the moon.
It can be a group of
students with a dream
and that one unified vision.
These students can do it.
My grand dream for the mission
is that Iris will drive one meter,
once it gets to the moon.
Tel, this is flight on ops.
Do you copy?
Copy.
Sys, this is flight.
Do you copy?
Copy.
Proceed to navigate
towards the NSS
on the far side of the lander.
Iris request permission
to deploy from the lander.
The mission success
comes from the rover
deploying, driving,
taking a picture
and sending a picture
back to Earth.
Even if things go
wrong after that,
it can do the basics and it shows
that in future
iterations, it's possible.
So many thousands of
things have to be right
to get that far.
And of course, anything
that goes wrong
can be a fatal glitch.
Every rover mission
has two landings.
There's one where the
lander makes it to the moon.
And the second,
more important one
is when the rover
gets to the surface.
All the other rovers
have had big ramps
they could roll down
or mechanisms that would
place them on the surface
or for Mars, a long cable
that lowers them
right to the surface.
This is the very first
that will drop-deploy.
When it's in the moon,
it's released and it
floats to the surface.
Our hope is that it
lands on level, easy terrain.
Other challenges are the
customary ones from space:
vacuum, heat, cold,
radiation, violent shaking.
Success is never forgone.
And anything beyond
a little bit of driving
on the moon
is all bonus.
We are a payload on
Astrobotic’s Peregrine Lander.
Which is then a payload
on the ULA Vulcan rocket,
the main rocket that will take it
to orbit and eventually the moon.
Physically, Iris is complete.
Every mechanical thing,
every electronic thing,
every little iota of the
physical parts are done.
Iris is onboard the lander.
Iris is ready to go to the moon.
And what remains is to
refine our procedures, our training, our team.
It will be operating
the robot right here,
from this room,
when it’s on the moon.
Any rover is risky business.
When it's Lean development,
without the big money,
without the long duration,
without the
aerospace infrastructure,
without the deep,
deep experience,
it's even riskier.
And something wonderful
about working with students
is that their threshold
for risk is consistent
with what had to be
to make Iris a reality.
Over 300 students,
almost 400 students
have participated
in this since 2017.
The fact that it's students
volunteering their time
or taking a class
that they get to have that
impact is just, it's extraordinary.
These students are going to be
going out and being
the next generation
in the space industry
and bringing this experience
to the next rover or
to the next rocket,
to the next world that we go to.
They are the ones that
have brought the creativity,
the courage, the drive,
the indefatigable work
and the pursuit of excellence
and have made it possible.